[Music]
while the day was wrapping up for most
of the Western world's Nintendo was just
getting started
releasing a slew of news that's sure to
have something you'll find worth getting
excited about
I'm just MacDonald and good Lord they
did have a lot of things to say so we
better get started the publisher
revealed during an earnings call that
the Nintendo switches paid online
service will launch in September of this
year online play for switch games has
been free since the system launched in
March but come September you'll need to
dig into your pockets the paid service
was intended to launch in fall of last
year but was delayed at the time
Nintendo said memberships would cost $4
for one month eight dollars for three
months and $20 for 12 months
by comparison both PlayStation Plus and
Xbox Live Gold cost $60 a year your
subscription will buy you access to
online game play and online Lobby and
voice chat as well as some ashab deals
Nintendo weren't finished there though a
new Mario Kart game called Mario Kart
tour was revealed for mobiles all we
know so far is that it's in development
now and will arrive by the end of March
next year so sit tight if you came for
this one well and truly switching gears
a Nintendo also revealed more details
about the upcoming animator - Super
Mario movie as suspected illumination
the studio behind Despicable Me &
minions will produce the film production
will be led by Despicable Me franchise
producer Chris Mel and Andrey and Mario
creator Shigeru Miyamoto the movie is
expected to arrive before the Tokyo
Olympics in 2020 for everything else
which Nintendo and our global fingers
being crossed for this upcoming Mario
movie to actually be good stay tuned to
games bud
[Music]